Yeah, I mean, it sounds like you might run a marathon before I do. You want to run a marathon? No, it's too long. Connor, that's not, that doesn't make me feel good. It doesn't make me feel good to hear that you think it's too long. welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 112 recorded on January 4th 2022 my name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce we conclude our 2022 retrospective and talk about Bryce's 2023 running goals all right is that so that's the 2022 summary. No personal stuff? No personal 2022 highlights?
是的，我是说，听起来你可能比我先跑马拉松。你想跑马拉松吗？不，太长了。康纳，那不对，这让我感觉不太好。听到你觉得太长，我感觉不太好。欢迎来到第112集 ADSP 播客，录制于2022年1月4日。我是康纳，今天与我的联合主持人布赖斯一起，我们总结了2022年回顾，并谈论了布赖斯2023年的跑步目标。好吧，这就是2022年的总结。没有个人的事情吗？没有个人的2022年亮点吗？
I mean, there's lots of work-related things that I'm proud of. I'm proud of a ton of the work that the C++ Core Library team at NVIDIA has done in the last year. We recently released our, our implementation of super-spoilers senders and, and that's now on GitHub. I think that's been pretty cool. It's a big accomplishment and we made a ton of progress on the, the proposal for senders in the committee. There's all this, you know, this quantum C++ stuff that I've been very, had a very limited amount of work on,
我是说，有很多我引以为豪的工作相关的事情。我为英伟达的 C++ 核心库团队在过去一年中做的大量工作感到自豪。我们最近发布了我们对超级剧透发送者的实现，现在它在 GitHub 上。我认为这真的很酷。这是一个巨大的成就，我们在委员会关于发送者的提案上取得了巨大的进展。还有所有这些，你知道，量子 C++ 的东西，我对此投入了很多，但工作量非常有限。
but it's still pretty cool. Glad to be involved in that. I'm pretty proud of everything that the C++ Library Evolution Group has gotten done the past year, starting the transition from completely remote to hybrid. Proud of the shape and scope of C++23. So yeah, I think those are my 2022 highlights. And I got to go to some great conferences. That's another 2022 highlight for me,
但它仍然很酷。很高兴能参与其中。我为 C++ 库演进小组在过去一年中所完成的一切感到自豪，包括开始从完全远程向混合模式过渡。我为 C++23 的形态和范围感到自豪。所以，是的，我认为这些就是我的2022年亮点。我还去了一些很棒的会议。这是我的另一个2022年亮点，
the return of the C++ face-to-face conferences. That's been fun. Yep. Well, that's my perfect segue. So Bryce, very unstructured. Even though I gave him advance warning, I say come up with your top things. Connor has a list. No, I have a list here. I wrote a list. Whoa, look at that. Did you miss anything on your list? Then another line that says return of C++ face-to-face conferences. And then 2023 says Empire Strikes Back and lists some details.
C++ 线下会议的回归。那很有趣。是的。好吧，这正合我意。所以布赖斯，非常随性。尽管我提前提醒过他，我说列出你最重要的几件事。康纳有一个清单。不，我这里有个清单。我写了一个清单。哇，看那个。你漏掉清单上的任何东西了吗？然后另一行写着 C++ 线下会议的回归。然后2023年写着帝国反击战并列出了一些细节。
And then says there's also a line item for Rust because I think Rust is going to continue gaining popularity this next year. Yeah, yeah. I was very excited. So yesterday or a couple days ago, Tom Palmer, I'm really hoping I got that name right. He's the context-free YouTube individual or has a YouTube by the name of context-free that posts a lot of programming language stuff. He has a website called Languish, which is programming language rankings based on GitHub statistics. And Rust has been trending very much upwards over the last few years. And C++ has kind of been static.
然后说还有关于 Rust 的条目，因为我认为 Rust 在接下来的一年里会继续普及。是的，是的。我非常兴奋。所以昨天或几天前，汤姆·帕尔默，我真的很希望我没记错那个名字。他是 context-free YouTube 个人或拥有一个名为 context-free 的 YouTube 频道，发布了很多编程语言的内容。他有一个名为 Languish 的网站，这是基于 GitHub 统计数据的编程语言排名。在过去几年里，Rust 的趋势一直在大幅上升。而 C++ 基本上一直处于静态。
And then C has also kind of been up and down. And Go has also been on the rise. So I usually look at those four languages. And it looked, based on the trend, that Rust was number 11, and it was going to hop into the top 10 and kick down C. But actually what happened was C++ went down, but the ranking stayed the same, and they're just above Go at the moment. So next quarter, because they update the stats every three months,
然后 C 语言也有些起伏。Go 语言也在崛起。所以我通常看这四种语言。根据趋势，Rust 当时排在第11位，它将进入前10名并把 C 挤下去。但实际上发生的是 C++ 下降了，但排名保持不变，它们目前刚好排在 Go 的上方。所以下个季度，因为他们每三个月更新一次统计数据，
Go might overtake C++. And Rust actually went down to 12, and I think C went down to 11 because Markdown somehow popped up into the top 10, which in my opinion isn't really a programming language, but it's in the statistics. Well, didn't we have a whole discussion once about is HTML a programming language? I felt bad about that. I take that back. HTML is a programming language, I think, now.
Go 可能会超越 C++。而 Rust 实际上下降到了第12位，我想 C 下降到了第11位，因为 Markdown 不知怎么地冲进了前10名，在我看来这并不是真正的编程语言，但它确实在统计数据中。好吧，我们不是曾经讨论过 HTML 是不是编程语言吗？我为此感到难过。我收回这话。我想现在 HTML 是一门编程语言了。
If HTML is a programming language, why isn't Markdown a programming language, I think, now. If HTML is a programming language, why isn't Markdown a programming language? Can't HTML do a lot more than Markdown? Markdown is like a completely watered-down version of what is possible with HTML. You know, I feel like every time in the history of computing that somebody has said, like, this thing has got limited capabilities or it's a
如果 HTML 是一门编程语言，为什么 Markdown 不是一门编程语言，我想，现在。如果 HTML 是一门编程语言，为什么 Markdown 不是一门编程语言？HTML 难道不能做比 Markdown 多得多的事情吗？Markdown 就像是 HTML 可能实现的功能的一个严重阉割版。你知道，我感觉计算历史上的每一次，当有人说，比如，这个东西功能有限或者它是一个
watered-down version like two or three years later they're they're eating crow because somebody's written a you know a brain fuck interpreter in whatever that thing was yeah it is i was upset the other day i was listening to uh was it no No, it was Python Bytes, which is a Python podcast. And they were reviewing, I mean, the survey came out months ago, I thought, the 2022 Stack Overflow Survey. And they were getting upset because of the way the top programming languages question was done because it asks you to list all the technologies you've worked with and not your primary one.
阉割版，两三年后他们就会自食其果，因为有人用那个东西写了一个脑残解释器，不管那是什么东西，是的，确实是这样。我前几天很不高兴，我在听，呃，是吗？不，是 Python Bytes，这是一个 Python 播客。他们在回顾，我是说，调查几个月前就出来了，我想，2022年 Stack Overflow 调查。他们很不高兴，因为顶级编程语言问题的问法，因为它要求你列出你使用过的所有技术，而不是你的首选技术。
And then because of that, SQL was like at the top of the list. And they were like, well, SQL is not a language. Like, you know, we shouldn't count that because people don't do it primarily. And I was like, that's so like SQL is definitely like. There's definitely, that's definitely a job. That's definitely a job description. And I think they were just upset because they lean, their bias is so hard towards Python. Like even, what was it, like when it was technologies that get used, they were upset that.NET was above Pandas and NumPy.
然后正因为如此，SQL 排在了榜单的前列。他们就说，嗯，SQL 不是一门语言。就像，你知道，我们不应该把这个算进去，因为人们主要不用它。然后我就觉得，这太像 SQL 了，绝对是。这绝对是一份工作。这绝对是一个职位描述。我想他们只是不高兴，因为他们倾向于，他们的偏见太倾向于 Python 了。就像甚至，是什么来着，当它是被使用的技术时，他们对 .NET 排在 Pandas 和 NumPy 之上感到不满。
And they were like, well, that's not a fair comparison because.NET is a whole – and I was just like, Jesus, anytime a Python thing gets knocked down because some other technology, they're coming up with excuses for why it shouldn't be included in the survey or why it's not fair that the survey was conducted. And I was just like – anyways, it's just – we're all biased, but it just seems very – not disingenuous, but it's very weird when you're listening to a Python podcast and they're kind of getting upset that like, oh, well, you know, SQL. Do people even really use that as a full-time thing? They just use it on the side, maybe know, maybe a couple lines a year. It shouldn't be, shouldn't count. And I'm like, I mean, there's, SQL is very, very important. And to call it one of the most popular languages in the world, I don't think is an inaccurate statement.
他们就说，嗯，这不公平的比较，因为 .NET 是一个完整的——我当时就想，天哪，每当一个 Python 的东西因为其他技术而被击落时，他们就会找出借口，解释为什么它不应该被纳入调查，或者为什么进行这项调查是不公平的。我当时就想——不管怎样，这只是——我们都有偏见，但当你听一个 Python 播客时，他们对诸如，哦，好吧，你知道，SQL 感到有点不满，这似乎很不——不是不真诚，但非常奇怪。人们真的把它当作全职工作吗？他们只是顺便用一下，也许知道，也许一年写几行。它不应该，不应该算数。而我想，我是说，有，SQL 非常非常重要。把它称为世界上最受欢迎的语言之一，我认为这并不是一个不准确的说法。
Anyways. All right. 2022. My number three, you didn't list it. Very hurt, Bryce. Very hurt. Was our trip to San Diego, PLDI. Oh, that was great.
不管怎样。好吧。2022年。我的第三名，你没有列出来。我很受伤，布赖斯。我很受伤。是我们去圣迭戈的旅行，PLDI。哦，那太棒了。
It was great. You know, I turned it into a little bit of a kind of vacation on the ends of the weekend surrounding it. But yeah, PLDI was awesome. Number two is switching to research. That's like been a dream job. And number one, it was the same as my number one for anyone that has been listening for over a year and they remember has been running but you know what we said at the end of our episode last year when we did this was we we had a bet or like a contest do you remember what that was yeah oh shit i'm gonna have lost this because it was we were comparing i think i you asked how far i'd run and then i
那太棒了。你知道，我把它变成了围绕周末的某种假期。但是，是的，PLDI 太棒了。第二名是转行做研究。那就像是梦想的工作。第一名，对于听了超过一年并还记得的人来说，和我的第一名一样，一直是跑步，但你知道我们去年这个时候在这一集结束时说过什么吗，我们有一个赌局或者说比赛，你还记得那是什么吗？是的，哦，见鬼，我肯定输了，因为那是我们正在比较，我想我你问我跑了多远，然后我
don't know it was 3 000 or or 4,000 and then you were checking to see if you had biked more than I ran and then you said that's not even really a fair contest and so you said for 2022 your goal was to bike at least twice as much as I had run during the year and potentially you did because I remember when we were I can't remember if it was in San Diego or in CPP North. At some point we were in the same city and you were like, I got to go. I got to go. I got to go hop on the,
不知道，是3000还是4000，然后你在检查你骑自行车是不是比我跑得远，然后你说这甚至算不上一个公平的比赛，所以你说对于2022年，你的目标是骑自行车的距离至少是我当年跑步距离的两倍，潜在地你确实做到了，因为我记得当我们在，我不记得是在圣迭戈还是在 CPP North。我们在某个时候在同一个城市，然后你说，我得走了。我得走了。我得走了，去骑，
um, the, what do you call it? Not an electric bike. What do you like? Biking? Well, I,
嗯，你叫它什么？不是电动自行车。你喜欢什么？骑自行车？嗯，我，
I, I rode biking. I've definitely not, um, not done more than you, but I do keep track of all of my... I mean, that counts, whether you're out on the road. That would be like saying I don't get to count running on a treadmill. I'm in Strava right now, and I can't figure out how to access last year's.
我，我骑过自行车。我绝对没有，嗯，没有做比你更多的事，但我确实追踪了我的所有……我是说，这算数，不管你是不是在路上。那就好比说我不把在跑步机上跑步算在内。我现在在 Strava 上，我找不到怎么访问去年的数据了。
We'll cut all this out all right how much how much what's your total distance my total this it doesn't give a breakdown for an inside outside of running but in 2022 my total distance is My total distance. It doesn't give a breakdown for an inside outside of running, but in 2022, my total distance is 4,482 kilometers. 4,482. So you're going to have to be basically very close to 9,000, 8,000. I do not think I am. Cause I,
我们把这些都剪掉吧，好吧，多少，多少，你的总距离是多少？我的总，这没有给出跑步室内室外的细分，但在2022年，我的总距离是我的总距离。这没有给出跑步室内室外的细分，但在2022年，我的总距离是4,482公里。4,482。所以你基本上必须非常接近9,000，8,000。我不认为我是。因为我，
I haven't been doing, uh, uh, the bike the entire time inside. I've been doing a good bit, um, uh, on the, like the cross trainer. Um, so I've got 3,888 on the cross trainer, um, and 489 inside. So, so 4,000, like 4,400 in total. So it didn't even beat me at 1.0.
我并没有一直，呃，呃，一直在室内骑自行车。我做了相当一部分，呃，呃，在，比如交叉训练器上。嗯，所以我交叉训练器上有3,888，嗯，室内有489。所以，所以4,000，大约4,400总计。所以它甚至没有在1.0时击败我。
Yeah. Yeah. But I think that that's, that's because I've been, I haven't, I just haven't been biking as much. A lot of it's been on the cross trainer. Oh yeah.
是的。是的。但我认为那是，那是因为我一直在，我只是没有骑那么多自行车。很大一部分是在交叉训练器上。哦，是的。
Where you cover a lot more. This app here tells me how many calories I burned. Does, do you have a way to get that information? Uh, it says activities, 316, distance, which we already covered,
这个应用程序告诉我我燃烧了多少卡路里。你有没有办法获取这些信息？呃，它说活动316次，距离我们已经讨论过了，
time, 377 hours. It does not look like it tells me calories. Although my Garmin app might. Because I know Garmin tracks my calories. Also, I have from my little tracker here, I have climbed 437 kilometers. 4,000 kilometers? 437 kilometers.
时间377小时。它看起来没有告诉我卡路里。虽然我的佳明应用程序可能会。因为我知道佳明会追踪我的卡路里。另外，从我这里的小追踪器上，我爬升了437公里。4,000公里？437公里。
4,000 kilometers? 437. What is that, hiking or biking? That's height gain from the gym, from stair machines, stuff like that. Damn, you got me beat there. I mean, my... Well... Actually, no, never mind. My elevation gain is... 21,000 meters? What is that?
4,000公里？437。那是什么，徒步还是骑车？那是来自健身房的高度增加，来自楼梯机之类的东西。见鬼，你在那方面把我打败了。我是说，我的……好吧……其实，算了，没关系。我的海拔上升是……21,000米？那是什么？
21 kilometers? Yeah. You said you had 4,000, no? No, no, no. I have 437 kilometers. Of elevation gain? Yeah. Isn't that going to like the moon or something, man?
21公里？是的。你说你有4,000，对吧？不，不，不。我有437公里。海拔上升？是的。那不是要去月球什么的吗，老兄？
Yeah, maybe. I don't know. Wait, how far? For calories, I have 100. Oh, shit. Never mind. I was off by like three orders of magnitude. Yeah.
是的，也许吧。我不知道。等等，多远？对于卡路里，我有100。哦，见鬼。没关系。我差了大约三个数量级。是的。
Or two orders of magnitude. The moon is further away. It's 384,000 kilometers away. So whoops. The moon is further away than. I apologize to the astronomers that are listening that just died laughing. I have 170,000 calories burned. And I still lost, like, no weight this year.
或者两个数量级。月球更远。它距离384,000公里。所以，哎呀。月球比……远。我向正在听并笑死的盲人天文学家道歉。我有170,000卡路里的消耗。我今年还是没瘦。
Yeah, I have no idea. I mean, it tells me... What's your average pace for minutes per kilometer? Doesn't look like it tells me that either. Anyways, I have exciting news for you. What is your news that you're gonna be exciting news is that uh i may start running whoa look at that because i was uh perfect in the city and uh we were trying to get to our favorite restaurant before it uh closed and so i was running a little bit and i was like you know what this is not miserable this isn't like the worst thing i've ever done um
是的，我不知道。我是说，它告诉我……你每公里的平均配速是多少分钟？看起来它也没告诉我这个。不管怎样，我有个好消息要告诉你。你的好消息是什么，你要说的好消息是，呃，我可能会开始跑步。哇，看那个，因为我当时，呃，在城里非常完美，呃，我们正试图在它关门之前去我们最喜欢的餐厅，所以我跑了一小会儿，然后我就想，你知道吗，这并不悲惨，这不是我做过的最糟糕的事情，嗯，
and so and and also um you're right next you're right next to central park too man it's like running one of the best places i'm actually that's the one downside of where i live is that uh well in manhattan i'm actually oh yeah that's that's that's right that's right i was thinking that you were next to um the sushi restaurant which you're not yeah um and i'm pretty far away from uh uh oh the sushi restaurant we went to that's the one on the west side i'm talking about the one of it on the east side the sugarfish on the east side yeah yeah um which is it's also further away from Central Park. We're in a really nice location, but for like the upper part of Manhattan, we're actually
所以，而且，嗯，你旁边，你旁边也是中央公园，老兄，这就像在最好的地方跑步一样。实际上，这是我住的地方唯一的一个缺点，那就是，嗯，在曼哈顿，我其实，哦，对，对，对，对，我以为你在，嗯，那家寿司餐厅旁边，但你不在，嗯，离得挺远的，嗯，哦，我们去的那家寿司餐厅，那是西区的那家，我说的是东区的那家，东区的 Sugarfish，对，对，嗯，离中央公园也更远。我们在一个非常好的地理位置，但对于曼哈顿的上半部分，我们其实
in a place that's pretty far away from Central Park. However, the girlfriend also used to run and she's feeling like she's getting out of shape. Absolutely not true, but she still feels like she's getting out of shape. And she hasn't been able to exercise as much the past few months. absolutely not true, but she still feels like she's getting out of shape. And, um, uh, and she hasn't been able to exercise as much the past few months. And so I keep telling her, you gotta, you should come exercise with me every day. And she's like, yeah, I should, we should do that. And, uh, and so now I'm thinking, well, maybe, maybe we could do running together because that's something that she used to do. There's this perfect, perfect man. And you know what? And
在一个离中央公园相当远的地方。然而，女朋友以前也跑步，她觉得自己正在走样。绝对不是真的，但她依然觉得自己正在走样。而且她过去几个月没能经常锻炼。绝对不是真的，但她依然觉得自己正在走样。而且，嗯，嗯，她过去几个月没能经常锻炼。所以我一直告诉她，你得，你应该每天跟我一起锻炼。她说，对，我应该，我们应该这么做。而且，嗯，所以现在我在想，好吧，也许，也许我们可以一起跑步，因为那是她以前做过的事情。这是个完美，完美的主意。你知道吗？而且
then it makes it easier from traveling and I don't have access to a gym. Yep. It's, I mean, I'm starting a running podcast this month. You're starting a running podcast. With one of my best friends from university, Yubai, and he was a varsity track athlete. He used to run 800 meters, so was very, very fast back in university, but he hasn't been running for a while either. And, uh, I told him that we're going to start a podcast and then I'm going to force him to join my run club. And, uh, it's going to follow the journey, our journey, because he's going to be getting
这样旅行时就更方便了，而且我不用去健身房。是的。我是说，我这个月要开始一个跑步播客。你要开始一个跑步播客。和我在大学最好的朋友之一，宇柏，他曾是大学田径队的运动员。他以前跑800米，所以在大学时非常非常快，但他有一段时间也没跑步了。而且，嗯，我告诉他我们要开始一个播客，然后我要强迫他加入我的跑步俱乐部。而且，嗯，这将跟随这段旅程，我们的旅程，因为他将要重新
back into running, but he's also like way more knowledgeable about training and stuff. Cause he did it for, for years when he was in university. Um, yeah. Anyways, this is great this is great yeah and there's a couple people in the c++ community i think barry uh who we mentioned earlier um or might maybe that might have been before we hit the record button um i think he he's more of a swimmer but i think he runs now and teamer also released that c++ lightning talk about best places to run at c++ conferences so maybe we'll get to run together so how do i get started how do i start running just honestly my recommendation to people is do the as much as you want to like most people but i want to do like 30 seconds to two minutes and then i'm like no i would I would like to walk now. Do that. Do that. Literally. Like there are a lot of running programs for like what they call like couch to 5k, which
开始跑步，但他对训练等方面的知识也渊博得多。因为他在大学时做过多年。嗯，不管怎样，这很棒，这很棒，是的，而且 C++ 社区里有几个人，我想巴里，我们之前提到过的那个人，或者可能那可能在我们按下录音按钮之前，我想他更擅长游泳，但我想他现在也跑步了。蒂姆还发布了关于 C++ 会议上最佳跑步地点的 C++ 闪电演讲，所以也许我们能一起跑步。那么我该如何开始，我该如何开始跑步？老兄，说实话，我对人们的建议是想跑多久就跑多久，就像大多数人一样，但我想跑大约30秒到2分钟，然后我就想，不，我
is like, I don't run and I want to run a 5k race. A lot of the recommendations there are like run for a minute, walk for a minute, run for a minute and do that. Even if you only go out and do that for 10 minutes, like that's where you start. And like at first, depending on your fitness level, that might seem extremely easy, but like a lot of like, I think the number one problem for people with like starting to run is actually just the starting part. Because if you tell someone, Hey, you have to go out and run nonstop for 60 minutes, like that just for a lot of people, it sounds boring and it's, it's very hard to get
现在想走路了。那就那样做。就这样做。字面意思。就像有许多跑步计划，比如他们所谓的“从沙发到5K”，也就是
motivated to go and do that. But like, if you just tell yourself, you know, I think there's a couple different, like Jason and I talked about this at one point, Jason Turner about like, as soon as you get out the door, like that's the hardest part. And then it's like, even if you tell yourself, you know, you know, I want to read a book or something, but your goal is like, I'm going to read like a page a day. It's like, well, once you've read, once you've read one page, it's like, well, I mean, I can read a little bit more than that. So like once you get out the door and have your shoes on, you know, it's usually easy to run, you know, whether it's one kilometer or five minutes, 10 minutes, whatever you want. And, uh, then you just start increasing that ratio. So if you go
我不跑步，我想跑一公里5K。那里的很多建议都是跑一分钟，走一分钟，跑一分钟，就这样做。即使你只出去做10分钟，那就是你的起点。而且一开始，根据你的体能水平，这可能看起来极其简单，但就像很多，我认为人们开始跑步的第一大障碍实际上只是开始的那部分。因为如果你告诉某人，嘿，你必须出去不停地跑60分钟，那对很多人来说，听起来很无聊，而且很难被
from running a minute, uh, walking a minute to like running for two minutes and walking for a minute until you get to the point where you can just run nonstop. And I mean, I personally, like I got a little bit stomach ill over the holidays and like didn't want to go out and run. Yeah. And so I went and just used the treadmill because I didn't really have the energy to leave. And like I, on an average per day, run like an hour and a half. And I like I love it. I'm addicted to it. It's like one of the most important things in my life. Running on the treadmill was like, it was like, I was dying inside. I just like, whatever it is, like not, not having the moving like there was a health podcast that mentioned something called optic flow, which is I don't
激励去那样做。但是，如果你只是告诉自己，你知道，我认为有几种不同的，比如杰森和我曾在某个时候谈论过这个，杰森·特纳关于，一旦你迈出家门，那是最难的部分。然后就像，即使你告诉自己，你知道，你知道，我想读一本书什么的，但你的目标是，我要一天读一页。这就好比，一旦你读了，一旦你读了一页，就会想，好吧，我是说，我可以比那多读一点。所以一旦你迈出家门并穿好鞋子，你知道，通常很容易跑步，无论是跑一公里还是5分钟、10分钟，随你便。而且，然后你只需开始提高这个比例。所以如果你从
know if it's complete made up, you know, garbage, but there's been some studies done that show that like one of the best things for thinking and like getting yourself, um, your brain activated and stuff is like optic flow, which is whether you're being in a car and you're seeing things go by you or you're biking or you're running, like having like the physical world move past you is like the brain likes it. And for whatever reason, like I had the hardest time even getting to 60 minutes on a treadmill. Whereas when I'm outside and I've got my podcast or music or whatever, I can run,
跑一分钟，走一分钟，到跑两分钟，走两分钟，直到你能够不停地跑。我是说，我个人，我在假期里胃有点不舒服，不想出去跑步。是的。所以我去用了跑步机，因为我真的没有力气离开。就像我，平均每天跑一个半小时左右。我喜欢它。我对此上瘾了。这是我生活中最重要的事情之一。在跑步机上跑步就像，就像我在里面垂死挣扎。我只是，不管是什么，就像没有，没有移动就像有一个健康播客提到了一种叫做光流的东西，我不知道
you know, hour and a half, two hours. And even if it's like, if it's raining, it's snowing, like I always prefer being outside. And so that would be my other recommendation is I think whether you want to
它是不是完全编造的垃圾，但有一些研究表明，对思考和激活大脑等最好的事情之一就是光流，也就是无论你是在车里看到东西从身边掠过，还是你在骑自行车或跑步，让物理世界从你身边移过，大脑喜欢它。不管出于什么原因，我在跑步机上甚至连60分钟都坚持不下来。而当我在外面，听着我的播客或音乐或别的什么时，我可以跑，
listen to the optic flow studies is that at least for me, I find treadmill running just like so boring. And it's also just like the time seems to go by so much slower. Whereas like I'll hit the 5k mark, um, of, uh, however long I'm going to run. And it's just like, it just disappears when you're outside by the, you know, the waterfront in Toronto is a very beautiful place to run. And, uh, it just like, it just disappears. Whereas you're in one spot just going blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah on a, on a treadmill. Um, yeah, it's, I mean,
你知道，一个半小时，两个小时。即使是在下雨、下雪，我也总是更喜欢在外面。所以这将是我的另一个建议，我想无论你想不想听那些光流研究，至少对我来说，我发现跑步机跑步太无聊了。而且也觉得时间过得慢得多。而我在外面，在多伦多的水滨，那里是一个非常美丽的跑步地方，我会达到我跑步计划的5K标志，它就那样消失了。当你身处户外时，它就消失了，而在跑步机上，你只是在一个地方喋喋不休地跑着。嗯，是的，我是说，
I, I sort of feel the same way too. It's like, it's easier for me if I can actually get out and bike, but, um, you know, I've been traveling so much and, uh, in the winter it's, you know, uh, you know, harder. Um, but, uh, I, I, I sort of like just going to the gym and just like being able to, you know, watch my show while I'm, you know, on the bike. And like when I was biking out, like in the city, I'll be listening to a podcast, but I don't mind, I don't mind just like being in the gym. I do feel like I get maybe more of a workout when I'm out like biking, um, like on an actual road. Um, and I, you know, usually feel a little bit better about that. Um, but, uh, I'm, I'm perfectly happy to, to, to do stuff inside
我，我也有同感。这就好比，如果我能真正出去骑自行车，对我来说会更容易，但是，你知道，我旅行太多了，而且在冬天，你知道，这更困难。但是，我，我，我有点喜欢去健身房，能够，你知道，在骑车的时候看我的节目。而且当我像在城里骑车时，我会听播客，但我不在乎，我不介意呆在健身房里。我确实觉得当我在外面像在真正的路上骑自行车时，我可能得到了更多的锻炼，而且我，你知道，通常对此感觉更好。但是，我，我非常乐意在室内
too. I forgot the other part of the, of the, uh, uh, the, the thing with the girlfriend, which is that, I don't know how we got on the topic, but, uh, uh, I think one of the two of us threatened to the other one, uh, that, that they couldn't run a marathon or that they shouldn't run a marathon or something like that. And, uh, long story short, uh, I think we came, uh, I, I told her we're gonna, we're gonna, we're gonna train to run and then we're going to go run the Sydney Marathon. I don't even know if there's a Sydney Marathon. I just like picked one of the travel destinations that we would like to go to. I assume that there is.
做这些事情。我忘了和女朋友那件事的另一部分，那就是，我不知道我们是怎么聊到这个话题的，但是，呃，呃，我想我们两个中的一个人威胁另一个人，呃，说他们不能跑马拉松，或者他们不应该跑马拉松什么的。长话短说，呃，我想我们达成了，我告诉她我们要，我们要，我们要训练跑步，然后我们要去跑悉尼马拉松。我甚至不知道有没有悉尼马拉松。我只是挑选了一个我们想去的旅游目的地。我假设是有的。
So that's our goal. We're going to run the Sydney Marathon. Sydney Marathon. It's a thing. I am going to. So you know that the London Marathon is right before, is right around when ACCU is this year. And I know this because my aunt is going to run the London Marathon.
所以这就是我们的目标。我们要跑悉尼马拉松。悉尼马拉松。那是真事。我打算。所以你知道伦敦马拉松就在 ACCU 今年举行的时候之前。我知道这一点是因为我阿姨要去跑伦敦马拉松。
Oh, wow. And she's going to be there at the same time that I am for ACCU. I mean, London's one of the majors, so it's very hard to get in. I'm sure Sydney's much easier. It's like, yeah, that's impressive. Your aunt must be. Yeah, she's a pretty good runner. Must be a pretty good runner.
哦，哇。她将在我和 ACCU 在同一时间到达那里。我是说，伦敦是大满贯赛事之一，所以很难进去。我确信悉尼要容易得多。就像，是的，这令人印象深刻。你阿姨一定。是的，她是个相当不错的跑步者。一定是个相当不错的跑步者。
Yeah, she claims this will be the last marathon she'll do. How many has she done? I guess she's done a lot. She's run like pretty much every day of her life. I think for the past 30 or 40 years or something. Wow, that's impressive yeah yeah i mean uh it sounds like you might run a marathon before i do um you don't run a marathon nope that's too long i uh connor that's not that doesn't make me feel good it doesn't make me feel
是的，她声称这将是她做的最后一次马拉松。她跑过多少次了？我想她跑过很多次了。她几乎生命中的每一天都在跑步。我想在过去的30年或40年里左右。哇，那太印象深刻了，是的，是的，我是说，听起来你可能比我先跑马拉松，嗯，你不跑马拉松，不，那太长了，康纳，那不对，这让我感觉不好，听到你觉得
good to hear that you think it's too long no it, it's just because I have this thing where I like when I hit the two-hour mark. And I love – It takes more than two hours? Yeah. Well, the marathon, depending on – I mean the world record is like two hours and one minute. So unless if you're faster than Elliot Ketrogi, which I can confidently tell you that you're not, you're going to be running more than two hours. I might not be, but the girlfriend, she's really fast. Like she's short, but she's fast.
那太长，我感觉不好。不，这只是因为我有这样一个习惯，当我跑到两小时大关时。我喜欢——这需要两个小时以上？是的。好吧，马拉松，根据——我的意思是世界纪录大约是两小时零一分钟。所以除非你比埃利乌德·基普乔格更快，我可以自信地告诉你你没有，你将要跑两个小时以上。我可能不会，但女朋友，她真的很快。她虽然个子矮，但她很快。
I mean, I think the women's record is 2.14. So she's still probably not running. All right, I'll tell her that's the number. But yeah, I just have this thing where like, so here's my one minute take on marathons. I plan to run marathons and upgrade, but my goal is to just get faster so that I if I get faster at the shorter things, I'll hopefully be getting faster at the longer things. But also for half marathons, you don't really need to fuel like with a.k.a. You don't need to like eat gels and like consume calories, Whereas in a marathon, you have to like basically
我是说，我认为女子纪录是2小时14分。所以她大概还是不会跑。好吧，我会告诉她那是那个数字。但是，是的，我只是有这样一种感觉，所以这是我关于马拉松的一分钟看法。我计划跑马拉松并升级，但我的目标只是变得更快，如果我在较短的距离上变得更快，我希望在较长的距离上也会变得更快。而且对于半程马拉松，你实际上不需要像补充能量那样。你不需要吃能量胶和消耗卡路里，而在马拉松比赛中，你基本上必须
fuel. And I love running because it's so simple. You just put shoes on, maybe a coat if it's cold out in the winter, and then you just go run. You just go in a circle, go in a straight line and come back. You know, it's pretty straightforward. Whereas when you start running marathons, like you have to be concerned about one, like how are you going to fuel? What are you going to fuel with? Are you going to use gels? Are you going to use little syrupy things you need to carry like four to six of them with you so like you're running with shorts that need to have some form of pockets or some form of things to hold these anyways like as soon as you start getting into like you know you're running so long that there's like logistics involved and
补充能量。我喜欢跑步，因为它太简单了。你只需要穿上鞋子，如果冬天冷的话穿件外套，然后去跑步。你只要绕圈跑，直线跑然后回来。你知道，这很简单。然而，当你开始跑马拉松时，你必须关心一件事，比如：你将如何补充能量？你用什么补充能量？你会用能量胶吗？你会用那些小糖浆状的东西吗？你需要随身携带四到六个，所以你的短裤需要某种口袋或某种东西来装这些东西。不管怎样，一旦你开始涉足，你知道，你跑的时间那么长，以至于涉及后勤问题，
that you need to basically have the equivalent of a freaking sandwich uh you know it's i start to ask myself is you know like uh like what are we doing here um yeah uh and also too yeah just like running for three or four hours does not sound like it's i'm very impressed by like everyone in my run club they're all you know there's a huge group of them that are signing up to go and do berlin this year which is one of the other major there's six major marathons um for listeners that don't know that it's Chicago, New York, London, Berlin, Tokyo, and Boston. Yeah, it's very impressive. Let's listen to me again. Chicago, Chicago, New York are the two US ones. Or no, sorry, Chicago, New York, Boston.
你需要基本上拥有相当于一个该死的汉堡的三明治，你知道的，我开始问自己，你知道，比如，我们在做什么呢？是的，而且，嗯，跑三四个小时听起来也不像是我对跑步俱乐部里的每个人印象深刻，他们都是，你知道，其中有一大群人报名参加今年柏林马拉松，这是另外一个大满贯赛事，有六个大满贯马拉松，对于不知道的听众来说，它们是芝加哥、纽约、伦敦、柏林、东京和波士顿。是的，这非常令人印象深刻。再听我一遍。芝加哥，芝加哥，纽约是两个美国的。或者不，抱歉，芝加哥，纽约，波士顿。
Boston is, I think, considered like the, and this will upset the other cities, but it's considered like the premier one, especially for Americans. And then London, Berlin, and Tokyo. That's untrue. The New York one is, of course, the premier one because it's in New York the best I mean uh yeah I'm sure there's a a ton of runners that will fight with each other about which one is uh has sort of more esteem I mean Boston the reason I think most people are in agreement that Boston is is because like they shut down the whole city for a day and like even people that don't care about running go out and like it's turned the whole city turns into a party and I think there's typically a baseball game or something that happens that's timed to end with like what when like the biggest crowds are entering somewhere new york though i've heard that it's
波士顿，我认为被认为是，这会惹恼其他城市，但它被认为是首要的一个，尤其是对美国人而言。然后是伦敦、柏林和东京。那是不真实的。纽约的当然是首要的，因为它在纽约，是最好的。我是说，是的，我确信有一大堆跑步者会争论哪一个更有声望。我是说，波士顿，我认为大多数人一致认为波士顿之所以是这样，是因为他们关闭了整个城市一天，甚至那些不关心跑步的人也会出来，整个城市变成了一个派对，而且通常有一场棒球比赛或其他什么活动，其时间安排与大量人群进入某个地方相吻合。不过纽约，我听说
just like new york is amazing because other than a couple of the bridges you just have like people cheering the whole time like it's people yeah although super freaking annoying. I got, last year, I was taking stuff to my storage unit, which is on 1st and 62nd. Between 1st and York on 62nd. And I get in the Uber with the three crates for the storage unit. Guy drives me up. And, uh, and then like, I really, we both realized we get there that like, shit, the marathon's happening. Um, and the marathon comes either down set,
纽约太棒了，因为除了几座桥之外，你周围一直有人在欢呼，就像人们在，虽然超级烦人。我去年，我正在把东西运到我的储物单元，它在第一大道和第62街。在第一大道和约克大道之间的第62街。我带着三个储物单元的箱子上了优步。司机把我拉上去。然后，然后就像，我们俩到了那里才意识到，见鬼，马拉松正在进行。嗯，马拉松会从下面下来，
maybe it's down second, um, uh, like North of the Queensborough bridge. And so like, there's no way for me to get over to um uh to first in 62nd and and i i still i you know i was frustrated and occasionally make bad decisions when frustrated and so the guy's like i can just drop you here and instead of being like no take me back to my apartment i's like, I can just drop you here. And instead of being like, no, take me back to my apartment. I'm like, all right, fine. Just drop me here. And so then I get out and now I have like three crates of things. And like, I'm so frustrated that I sent the guy away that I don't even do the smart thing of like getting another Uber. I'm like, I'll just walk back. And so I walked back to my apartment and i had like i had like a little hand cart um and i took that hand cart from 60 second all the way back down to um uh to 51st and second
也许是沿着第二大道下来，呃，比如皇后区大桥以北。所以，就像我没法去到第一大道和第62街，而且我，我仍然，你知道我很沮丧，沮丧时偶尔会做出糟糕的决定，所以那家伙说我可以在这里把你放下，而不是像别那样，带我回我的公寓，我说，我可以在这里把你放下。而不是像别那样，说不，带我回我的公寓，我说，好吧，好吧。就在这里把我放下。然后我下了车，现在我有三个箱子的东西。而且，我很沮丧，我把那家伙打发走了，我甚至没有做明智的事情，比如再叫一辆优步。我心想，我走回去吧。所以我走回了我的公寓，我有一个小手推车，我把那个手推车从第62街一直推回到了，
um which is where we live and um yeah i was very unhappy like there's no it's just like okay like just for this day like you just can't cross over to this part of the city. Come on. If there's a parade, fine, because there'll be breaks in the parade and they'll let you through. But the marathon, they don't let you through. This is... I mean, there's 50,000 people that run it, so... There are some disruptions in New York that, like, I made peace with. Like, during the UN General Assembly, I had an Instacart delivery get canceled. And the guy sends me a message and he's like, I'm sorry, dude.
嗯，第51街和第二大道，那是我们住的地方，嗯，是的，我很不高兴，就像没有，这只是像，好吧，就为了这一天，你就是不能穿过城市的这一部分。得了吧。如果有游行，那好吧，因为游行会有间隙，他们会让你过去。但马拉松，他们不放行。这是……我是说，有5万人跑它，所以……纽约有一些我接受的中断。比如，在联合国大会期间，我的 Instacart 配送被取消了。那家伙给我发了一条消息，他说，我很抱歉，老兄。
Like, you know, Biden just flew in and like the bridges are like closed. Like I can't deliver your groceries because like Biden's motorcade is like closed everything off. And it's like, okay, like that's, you know what? That's fine. The president's coming into town. You know, I, I, I made my peace with that. But, but the marathon shutting down, shutting, shutting down so much in New York for the day, I don't like that.
就像，你知道，拜登刚刚飞进来，桥梁都关闭了。我没法送你的杂货，因为拜登的车队把一切都封锁了。这就好比，好吧，你知道吗？那没关系。总统要来镇上了。你知道，我，我，我接受了这一点。但是马拉松在纽约关闭了那么多地方一天，我不喜欢这样。
I mean, says the guy who's signed up to basically run a marathon in the future now, you're going to be – Yeah, but not in my city, in somebody else's city. The disruption can be somewhere else. I mean, I predict that if you run the Sydney Marathon, you're probably going to end up running the New York Marathon. Yeah, let's –'s i i as i told the girlfriend we can like maybe start with like a 5k or like a 1k yeah they got 1ks they got
我是说，这话出自一个现在报名准备在未来跑马拉松的人之口，你将要——是的，但不是在我的城市，在别人的城市。中断可以在别的地方。我是说，我预测如果你跑悉尼马拉松，你可能最终会去跑纽约马拉松。是的，让我们——正如我告诉女朋友的，我们可以像从5K或1K开始，是的，他们有1K，他们有
the the new york um the new york uh fifth avenue mile that's a exciting race to to run right by uh central park mostly downhill you pick up some speed, some serious speed. This is exciting. This is exciting. I guess I'll have to get running shoes. I'm sure the girlfriend has running shoes. She has a lot of shoes. Yeah.
纽约的，纽约的第五大道英里，那是一场激动人心的比赛，就在中央公园旁边跑，大部分是下坡，你会获得一些速度，一些真正的速度。这太令人兴奋了。这太令人兴奋了。我想我得买跑鞋了。我确信女朋友有跑鞋。她有很多鞋子。是的。
So some of them must be running shoes. That's my other tip is, I mean, depending. So hard for me to buy shoes. This is what I'll say is that like running shoes, especially running shoes these days, cause they're made so well, they have like a lifetime. Um, and some people, they say they can run on their shoes even until they get holes in them, like 2000 kilometers. Uh, I do not have that genetic gifts. And like, once I hit like the 600, depending on the type of shoe kilometer mark on a shoe,
所以其中一些一定有跑鞋。那是我的另一个建议，我是说，取决于。对我来说买鞋太难了。我要说的是，跑鞋，尤其是现在的跑鞋，因为它们制作得很好，它们有一个寿命。嗯，有些人，他们说他们甚至可以在鞋子上有洞之前穿着它们跑，比如2000公里。我没有那种基因天赋。而且，一旦我达到了600，取决于鞋子的类型，
even if it looks perfectly fine, like all of the cushion and stuff is like shot especially like i'll start to feel like pain right underneath my knees like at the top of my shins as soon as that starts happening i just knew i know i need a new pair of shoes um so like if you have i mean it could potentially be like form or something like that but um if you are running on like a pair of old trainers that are not specifically designed for whatever, yeah, you might want to just buy. And I would just go to like your local running shoes. Like people at running shoe stores, they typically know what they're doing. Yeah. And they'll hook you up.
公里大关，即使它看起来非常完美，所有的缓冲等东西也都耗尽了，尤其是当我开始感到膝盖下方，小腿顶部疼痛时。一旦开始发生这种情况，我只是知道，我知道我需要一双新鞋。所以，如果你有，我是说，这可能潜在地是由于跑步姿态什么的，但是，如果你穿着一双并非专门为某种东西设计的旧训练鞋跑步，是的，你可能只想买一双。我就会去你当地的跑步鞋店。跑步鞋店的人，他们通常知道自己在做什么。是的，他们会帮你搞定的。
Cool. All right. Well, wait. Do we have any other 2023 Slovenia goals for 2023? We're going to be in that general region this summer for the C++ committee meeting. So maybe. What do you mean maybe? We're definitely going.
酷。好吧，等等。我们还有2023年斯洛文尼亚的其他目标吗？今年夏天我们将去那个一般地区参加 C++ 委员会会议。所以也许吧。你什么意思也许吧？我们肯定会去的。
We've committed to the fans. I'm going to Slovenia. I guarantee the listeners that I will be in Slovenia at some point in 2023. Will Bryce be there? We don't know. Connor, you're making a threat to somebody who you know loves travel and too has not only great capabilities to figure out how to get to someplace like Slovenia, but also has like all the miles and the points and the things. So like this is...
我们向粉丝们承诺了。我要去斯洛文尼亚。我向听众保证，我将在2023年的某个时候出现在斯洛文尼亚。布赖斯会去吗？我们不知道。康纳，你这是在威胁一个你知道热爱旅行的人，而且不仅有很强的能力弄清楚如何去像斯洛文尼亚这样地方的人，而且还有所有的里程和积分以及各种东西。所以这就像是……
If I tell you when I'm going to be in Slovenia, can I just assume that you will show up? I mean, yeah. All right. The people of Slovenia, the people of Ljubljana, we're coming. I'm excited. It's quite a beautiful. We've seen photos when I was preparing for that show a year ago.
如果我告诉你我什么时候去斯洛文尼亚，我能假设你会出现吗？我是说，会的。好吧，斯洛文尼亚人民，卢布尔雅那人民，我们来了。我很兴奋。那真是个美丽的地方。当我们一年前为那个节目做准备时，我们看过照片。
It's pretty beautiful. I've also heard, speaking of running, that apparently Slovenia, I heard this on one of my running podcasts, has like a huge running community and they've got a bunch of really awesome races that like fly under the radar because i guess i don't know slovenia is not as well known as some other european countries yeah um anyways people get it confused with uh other countries yeah it is and i would i don't know why i thought but i thought slovakia would be close like bordering slovenia like as i just like figured while they were naming the country. Yeah, I think a lot of Americans would assume that, yeah. But it's not the case at all.
它非常美丽。我还听说，说到跑步，显然斯洛文尼亚，我在我的一个跑步播客上听到的，拥有一个庞大的跑步社区，他们有很多非常棒的比赛，这些比赛不太引人注目，因为我想我不知道斯洛文尼亚不像其他一些欧洲国家那么出名。是的，嗯，不管怎样，人们把它和其他国家弄混了。是的，它是，我不知道为什么我想，但我以为斯洛伐克会很近，与斯洛文尼亚接壤，就像我刚想的那样，当他们给国家命名时。是的，我想很多美国人会那样假设，是的。但事实并非如此。
And it's not. Slovakia borders Poland, but then it's a couple countries over. Yeah. Anyways, Empire Strikes Back. But I feel like everybody knows where Poland is because, you know, it's a big country. Yeah, it's very big. And is that just why people know? I guess it's next to ukraine right so i mean i'm sure most people were curious about the conflict and lifted a map and etc um uh well i
事实并非如此。斯洛伐克与波兰接壤，然后隔着几个国家。是的，不管怎样，帝国反击战。但我感觉每个人都知道波兰在哪里，因为，你知道，它是一个大国家。是的，它非常大。这就是人们知道的原因吗？我猜它挨着乌克兰，对吧？所以，我是说，我确信大多数人都对冲突感到好奇，并看了一眼地图等等，呃，嗯，好吧
would hope that i would hope that people know where poland is for reasons other than it's near ukraine uh i mean i've i've been there multiple times now I'll probably be in Poland next year a couple times probably at least once for visiting my girlfriend's family but also I'm hoping to get to Code Dive next year yeah yeah it's a great conference
我希望人们知道波兰在哪里不仅仅是因为它挨着乌克兰，呃，我是说，我现在已经去过好几次了，明年我大概还会去波兰几次，可能至少有一次是为了拜访我女朋友的家人，但我也希望明年能去参加 Code Dive，对，那是个很棒的会议。
I got oh yeah and I got my talk accepted to Lambda Days so Composition Intuition it's happening in krakow which is also in poland for listeners when is that that's in june and i'm thinking of maybe maybe turning that into like a bit of a travel vacation and then go and visiting some stuff which potentially i mean yeah it depends on if you can get to slovenia but if i
哦对，我的演讲被 Lambda Days 接受了，也就是关于“组合直觉”的那个，它将在克拉科夫举行，听众朋友们，这也是波兰的一个城市。那是几月？那是六月份，我在考虑也许可以把这变成一次度假之旅，去参观一些地方，这可能……呃，这取决于你能不能去斯洛文尼亚，但如果我
get accepted to c++ on c then that's at the end of june if you get accepted yes it's true i mean i've never submitted to uh the last before this talk composition intuition i think my last talk got rejected oh that's not true two talks ago. I submitted to speak at Strange Loop in 2022. Yeah, that looks like a cool conference. Yeah, I think it's actually it's over now. They've ended it
被 C++ on Sea 接受了，那是在六月底。如果你被接受了的话，是的，真的。我是说，我以前从来没有向……在这次关于组合直觉的演讲之前，我记得我上次的演讲被拒绝了，哦不对，不是这样的，是两个演讲之前。我在 2022 年申请在 Strange Loop 上演讲。对，那看起来是个很酷的会议。对，我想实际上它现在已经结束了。他们已经停办了
and the last thing I heard that 2023 was going to be the last edition of the conference but then if you click on the register oh no, it is back up.
我听到的最后消息是 2023 年将是该会议的最后一届，但接着如果你点击注册，哦不，它又恢复了。
Yeah, yeah. So I might go register for this right now because i've never been i would i would die to speak there but uh i mean i wouldn't die that's a figure of speech um it's actually paradoxical you can't speak if you're dead anyways um that is true yeah you can go register i'm not sure if they even have a call for papers or they're just going to do like the best of years past and and bring back speakers that have already spoken there because if i was running a conference that i had run for i don't know roughly a decade or more i would probably do something like that um but it does look like they are going to have a cfp that opens on april 3 So anyways, lots of stuff to look forward to. Yep.
对，对。所以我现在可能去注册，因为我从来没去过，我做梦都想在那里演讲，呃，我是说我不是真的会死，那只是一种修辞手法，呃，其实这很矛盾，反正你死了就没法演讲了，那是真的。你可以去注册，我甚至不确定他们是否会征集论文，或者他们只是打算选出历年来的最佳演讲，并请回以前在那里演讲过的嘉宾，因为如果我是个办了大概十年甚至更久的会议的组织者，我可能会那样做，但看起来他们确实会在 4 月 3 日开放征稿。总之，有很多事情值得期待。是的。
Slovenia, Empire Strikes Back. Any other predictions or things that need to be said going into the year 2023? None come to mind. None come to mind. All right. I guess I hope everybody has a, has a great year.
斯洛文尼亚，帝国反击战。对于 2023 年还有什么其他的预测或需要说的事吗？我想不出来了。我想不出来了。好吧。我想祝大家度过美好的一年。
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day and a great year. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家拥有美好的一天和美好的一年。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。